so just shows you size isn't everything
so look at this success story of
Germany's hidden champions now we'll
have platanus as he's an expert in
competitive strategy at the European
School of Management and Technology here
in Berlin and it's great to have you
with us you're probably familiar with
our show a bit we do have a series
that's called world champions or hidden
champions where we focus on German small
and medium-sized companies making a big
splash around the world c-deck is one of
them it's not an exception what's the
secret of their success you're right we
have many companies that are mid-sized
and very successful particularly the
export by the way and usually this is
based on a technology advantage that
they can offer to their customers and
the consumer goods we have a dock
leaders like flexi for example in the
b2b markets it's a little bit more
complicated with regard to technology
but they find their way they find their
niches but why do we have this advantage
German SMEs are the engineers they're
the people coming up with these ideas
simply better than the rest of the world
yeah the engineering ideas are often
rooted in Germany we have a very high
share of engineers at the University and
historically something has grown up that
is going into this direction but can
this go on forever and ever I mean there
are some companies some small and
medium-sized companies that used to be
hidden champions liver for one and and
and they got into trouble so there must
be some pitfalls also to watch out for
that's right so if you're in a free
market it can always happen that you
disappear usually there are two key
reasons first your products would get
over engineered so it becomes better and
better but the prices get higher and
higher and suddenly you don't find any
more customers that are willing to pay
the highest prices but it might be much
more important the second alternative
here and this is that more and more
competitors are showing up in the global
world and there
similar technology and then your
competitive advantage is fading away
right and this competitive advantage I
mean we're in the middle now at the
beginning perhaps of what many called
the fourth Industrial Revolution
industry 4.0 this a cyber Factory smart
grid and cyber automation and all that
that has less to do with engineering but
more with software our German SMEs up to
that one thing is clear they have to
change and it's not only that they go
from hardware to software by the way
Siemens
it is said they have now 17,000 a
software developer to do that oh but I
think it's even more important also to
adapt your business model okay